Johan said forget every single one of
you Johan tells the cast to go to hell
after they accuse him of scamming
Danielle that rhymes that's a
bar so my opinion this is past cheating
this is scamming he's not only a scammer
but he's a liar also like damn I have I
think if you're a scammer you're
automatically a liar Andre but we get
the point plus Armando questions Tim
sexuality and relationship with
Kenny I want to ask a question to Tim oh
God I know on text you call Kenny
Daddy are you sure nothing has gone down
in New York when you're there with him
my
God hey 90day fans fam It's Mia all
right it's time to dig into part two of
the tell all before we get into Johan
saying the hell was it when it comes to
some of our opinions let's get into
Kenny and Armando who revealed they had
a setback in their surrogacy process we
picked a egg donor and she went through
the whole process and the day she's
supposed to come in she ghosted the
clinic oh wow and never showed up never
did anything so we had to go through the
whole process again luckily they didn't
give up and now they have some great
news to share but I'm happy to say that
we have seven embryos now oh wow
congratulations for those of you who are
unaware an embryo is the initial stage
of development of a baby has the clinic
asked you how many eggs or embryos that
you want to try and
transfer let me tell you something
Sean we are are in a debate on this he
wants to implant two I want one I had
triplets I know it can happen that's how
I had triplets oh
wow and we have to decide in the next 15
days so what are you going to do that's
TBD so who knows Kenny and Armando could
be having a baby or babies all right
Switching gears to a light-hearted
moment that also brings some
clarity I want to ask a question to Tim
while discussing Kenny and Tim's close
relationship Armando raises a question
oh
God I know on text you call Kenny Daddy
are you sure nothing has gone down in
New York when you're there with him it's
like Armando is asking somewhat as a
joke but he's also serious what we we're
friends and he'll like message you say
hey Daddy what's up yeah and I show we
he knows it's all in fun cuz you know he
gets crap online about his orientation
and he's not but he is comfortable in
his own skin to play around like that
and stuff so he'll just say in a joking
way and he knows it he's not bothered by
it
either well right if he wasn't bothered
he wouldn't have brought it up I mean he
has been in my room quite a lot some
people think it but no we're just like
really we're tight we just get along we
have a good time with us it just
banged the wrong
word that just shows that people of
different orientation that can just goof
around and be friends and there's no
Hang-Ups like that or anything like that
I goof around but I trust him so what
he's told me is what it is and you know
it's all in fun it's fine that's such a
wonderful feeling to be in a
relationship where you might question
something or be bothered by something
but at the end of the day you can always
lean on the fact that you trust your
partner that's beautiful all right
moving on to Danielle and Johan an
example of what a relationship can look
like when the trust is completely broken
Danielle is still living in the
Dominican Republic even though she found
out Johan has been dating multiple women
one of them in particular he has
allegedly been in a relationship with
for 2 years since the month before their
wedding and it was also a sexual
relationship so when was the last time
you two saw each other in
person oh
okay how did that go um surprisingly
fine we had dinner with his family wait
you had dinner with his family wow in
the house that he lives in okay even
though you were separated yep H that
makes you wonder has she really let this
man go yet my next question would have
been when is the last time you two were
intimate with each other I know it's a
bit invasive but sometimes when it's
good it makes you stay around much
longer than you should I'm just trying
to make it make sense because there is
no way I would be breaking bread or
kiking with a man who has obviously been
scamming me and cheating with multiple
women what is she holding on to I get
that it can be tough to let long-term
relationships go but his actions should
be all the motivation she needs he's
lied and cheated and everything like he
doesn't deserve your time nor friendship
so why I value his mother his sisters
they're really good people and they deal
with a lot of terrible men like you can
still have on with them he just doesn't
need to
be you're right I hear Danielle but I
would be surprised if Johan's mom and
sister
didn't know what Johan was up to or his
true intentions with Danielle they might
not have known everything but I'm sure
they had a clue so they wouldn't
necessarily be on my good side either a
few episodes ago she said one of the
women he allegedly cheated with met some
of Johan's family she met his father and
his
nephew and gave them money H fast
forward Johan goes on to say that when
he and Danielle broke up they made an
agreement that they don't have to be
enemies and they can get along share a
meal and relax without any problems it
sounds so crazy but I do it because his
family is important to me because I want
to make sure that he's okay and he has
what he
needs I can kind of relate to Danielle
here there have been times where someone
has hurt or betrayed me and I still
found myself more concerned about their
feelings and wellbeing over mine I think
Danielle wanting to make sure Johan is
okay and has what he needs speaks to her
emotional capacity but I also think
she's doing him a disservice and babying
him by not allowing him to experience
the full repercussions that come with
treating people as if they're not human
and only objects to get you what you
want or to take you where you want to go
I can appreciate that it appears as if
she's attempting to lead with love but
you can do that from a distance let him
go girl he doesn't need you he was
surviving before you entered his life
two years
[Music]
ago they start to play back clips of
Johan complaining about Danielle not
giving him things and taking care of him
financially I want to point out this
comment quickly shamarie says why are we
forgetting Danielle asked him to quit
his good paying job because she was
jealous he'd meet someone else so why
the hell would she be asking him for
money I understand Johan's irritation
she got what she wanted so she should
deal with the consequences speaking of
that Danielle explains why she continued
to deal with what Shay calls quote the
consequences one of the reasons why I
put up with all the that he did was
because our day
today was so positive like we got up we
went to the beach the morning we
traveled every other weekend like the
majority of our life was really
beautiful as long as I was funding it so
to see like all of these sides of
him It's upsetting to me cuz he doesn't
have to be the
way Danielle goes on to say that all he
cares about is money and now he lives
with his parents and has nothing she
then goes on to Dish about all the
receipts she has about the multiple
women he's been talking to while married
to her including evidence that he's sent
nudes you know she gave me a
play-by-play of their entire
relationship and described every single
detail every time she saw him um sent me
pictures that he sent her one of them
was a picture of his on Christmas Eve
while I was handing out gifts to his
family in his neighborhood H talk about
a dirty Santa I went through his
computer and I found evidence of other
women that he's been in relationships
with that he spent the night with
um there are at least six different
women that I know have had an
inappropriate relationship with my
husband women that he's either reached
out to and asked for money that he's had
video conversations with that he's made
plans to meet up with and he sat here
and bitched all year that he was broke
meanwhile he's been getting money from
multiple
no I want nothing to do with this man
ever again yet she's having dinner with
him and his
family come on Daniel
bun says let's not pretend that Danielle
didn't lead Johan to believe he was
going to the states or having a baby
bunber adds Danielle got her karma how
many women since you two have been
together do you think Johan has
physically hooked up with so I don't
keep count I could use help from
sarper I don't keep count I have a lot
of screenshots but probably close to
like 50 or 60
what he slept with that I don't know I
don't know okay girl you got to clarify
because the question was how many has he
physically hooked up with I don't know
who he slept with and who he hasn't I
know that there are ones that I've
confirmed that he's met in person one of
them being one of my clients oh hell no
multiple women that he's reached out
come see me I want to see you I love you
like he has multiple even now cuz he
doesn't realize this but I can see every
message and everywhere in his
life he has multiple women that he's in
a relationship with and now that that
think that they're the only one
apparently she has his passwords Johan
um did you send a picture of your
private parts to another
woman but
but are you serious I have images of the
messages that he sent to these women and
that's not true it's just not true
there's there's evidence that that is
not the case of course Johan denies all
the cheating and scamming
allegations and then calls Daniel out
for putting him on this sanky Panky
Facebook page where women put photos of
the men they are dating in the Dominican
Republic to see if they are getting
scammed yeah she could have found a
better picture of them and dang he's
recruiting women from Europe and
Argentina if all of this is true all of
that energy Johan is using to recruit
lie ask for money send nudes he can be
using to build something substantial for
himself not saying it's going to be easy
but clearly the easy route he's been
taking by seemingly trying to scam
people doesn't
last and once again Europe Argentina and
Canada obviously this man has some
international business skills that he is
a applying the wrong way he can connect
with a variety of people he just needs
to get out of the business of trying to
scam them I've learned when you move
with Integrity you will always be taken
care of even if it appears as if you're
not winning in the moment in the end you
will always come out on top what does
Robert Green say the fools in life want
things fast and easy money success
attention all right back to the show so
my opinion this is past cheating this is
scamming yeah no it's scamming it's
cheating it's all that she's like wait
we're married so it is cheating let's be
clear he's not only a scammer but he's a
liar also like damn the cast starts to
share how they feel about the situation
and Armando admits he's been on Johan's
side this entire time because he feels
like Danielle emasculates him similar
thoughts that many of you have
but now Armando says he feels like Johan
used Danielle that's when Johan goes
off
I don't think either of them were
perfect in this relationship but
obviously as you can see based off the
recap I think Yan's sole intention for
marrying Danielle was to use her to get
what he wanted meanwhile she thought it
was love which I think he's just
completely wrong for that I'm curious to
hear your thoughts though especially the
people who have been team Yan this
season all right next week on part three
of the tell all we meet one of Johan's
women and he looks shooking just be
honest just for once in
life there have been a lot of women that
Johan has spoken with and we have one of
them with us today o this is about to
get real good all right 90day fan famam
make sure you stick with ET because we
are covering it all I will see you next
time